[dramatic music]
We are here to
document the lives
of people living in Alaska.
The harsh reality is the
environment we're up against.
It makes it tough to do our job.
Get out of there!
Working on "Life Below
Zero" can be very dangerous.
Guns here.
Cameras here.
Never know what to expect.
Hey!
You [bleep] see that [bleep]?
It's gonna be tough, but
we're gonna get the shot.
Every scenario, we
gotta prepare for this.
But we're still smiling.
We're having fun.
We're still making
"Life Below Zero."
Yes!
Bring it on.
[suspenseful music]
It's 9:00 AM, day five
of our extended stay
here at Chandalar.
Still waiting for a weather
window to get a plane in here.
It's beautiful blue
sky here, but the area
in between here and where we
need to get to is the problem.
We're wrapped,
but here we remain.
It's 13 days without
plumbing or heat.
Every day I thought--
including today--
I thought there was a really
good chance we would get out.
Messaging back and forth
via satellite to the office,
and they're doing our best--
their best to keep us
safe, so I appreciate that.
And we just gotta wait until
things are safe to get out.
What can you do?
Man makes plans and God laughs.
So this is our
gear pile staged
on the beach ready to
go if we get the call
that the plane is coming in.
We're just going
to leave this out
unless the weather
gets really bad.
We've run pretty low on food.
It's definitely getting to the
point where we're scraping by.
Some peanut butter, this
could come in handy.
A couple of cans of sardines.
That's about it.
Probably at about two or
three days of food left.
We moved into Glen's sod house.
It's got an open door and
then a hole in the roof.
Dragged our tarp over here
to kind of close up the roof
hole a little bit to keep
a bit more of the heat in.
We'd set up cots
that just barely
fit in the open space in there.
And it's been a pretty
great little home.
So here's our door to
keep the heat in at night.
It takes a little
bit of gymnastics
to get out in the
middle of the night
without making a lot of noise
and waking up your mates,
but it keeps the
heat in really well.
We need some wood to
keep our sod house warm.
We don't want to burn
all of Glen's wood,
so we're going to go out
into the forest and get some.
It'll keep us warm later, and
it'll warm us up right now
and give us something to do.
Well, you want a
standing dead tree,
so you're looking
for one that doesn't
have any green needles on it.
It doesn't seem like
it's green at all.
It seems like it's dead.
We could try for that one.
I think we could take that down.
I think it'd be fun.
[dramatic music]
Guy's a human beaver.
Starting to have
a little concern
about it falling the other way.
We'll see what happens.
Yeah, I think it wants
to go the other way.
It's almost ready to go, Tony.
Get out of there!
[crashing]
Yeah!
We got firewood.
So now that we've dropped
this tree on the ground,
we need to cut it up
into manageable pieces.
We're about a quarter mile
from the sod house right here,
so we're going to have to just
carry them on our shoulders.
We don't want to
cut them too big,
but we don't want to cut
them too small because that
means more cuts and more trips.
So we'll just take a guess
at what the right length is
and cut it up into some chunks.
Warm you up for sure.
You know what they say, Tony.
Wood warms you twice.
We've got the tree cut up
into four usable chunks
that I think we can manage to
carry out of here on our own.
So we'll do two trips.
We'll throw them up on our
shoulders, walk them out.
[dramatic music]
Good job.
That was fun.
Yeah, it was.
Thank you.
[birds hooting]
All right.
This should do us for the while.
Thanks for getting
all that wood, Natch.
Yeah, that was a fun project.
Yeah.
Good group effort.
It's getting colder every
night, and having all this wood
is a killer thing to do.
I mean, not only is it, like--
it's keeping us warm in here,
for one thing, for sure.
But just having something to
do, just trapped in this sort
of weird limbo that
we're in waiting,
waiting, waiting for a new
message from production,
a new message from
our friends or family,
and just trying to
find something to do
in the meantime to fill time.
One of my favorite
things about spending
an extended period of time
out in the backcountry
is it really gives
you an appreciation
for all the things that we
can kind of take for granted.
Food is a huge part
of that for the crew.
I'm very, very excited.
It smells amazing.
[soft music]